hey we we coming
we as in Lakers oh we coming
we ain't laying down so you counting the
Lakers as one of your teams would you
like me to shock you now and say it now
yeah go ahead Lakers tomorrow
guaranteed
nothing in here brother
okay if they drop something out of this
ceiling everybody better move that's
right it's gonna hurt like hell yeah so
Joker had 34 21 and 14. Shack like
numbers the question uh what are you
gonna do defensively against the guy and
here's uh Chris Haynes with a report
here in the Mahi City Anthony Davis
played off of the Joker in the second
half of game one with some success but
he admits it's problematic trying to
figure out when he should slide over and
help
that's why they pay me the big bucks I
gotta figure it out
that's my job I wanted to help everyone
do Christmas week protect God so
you got to mix up pitches you know I
gotta you know just read the floor of
the game and decide if we got him you
know do I fully commit you know and just
go blocks out Gordon or you know do I go
to help someone have my help on the back
side we attacked them we took a dealer
out the game
um that was our our goal um just to get
him involved in everything
um and then yeah we got easy ones going
Jamal is making tough shots uh yoko's
playing extremely well and in Mike and
kcp contributed to also we can't come
with a mod setup we have to match this
that they're doing we have to match
their tone and we have to be the tone
Setter and uh last time I checked me
into tone set it requires you to throw
the first punch sources tell me Darvin
ham is considering starting rui hachimar
for game two it's a decision he's
keeping very close to the vest back to
you guys very appropriate Haynes t-shirt
uh well I see you know he's got that
Tiger Woods thing working when he wears
that's medium well he should be wearing
a lot so he's not like the gold chain
one Bruce brown high points for uh
honesty and Candor in this post game I
don't think he should have said that say
what what is that he talked about
D'Angelo Russell we were going to attack
D'Angelo Russell every time we got a
chance don't tell that because don't
poke the bear that don't work out good
for you yes it does well let's get back
to your original question yeah what's
your question honey if Joe didn't have a
question I think you had a question then
you asked a question about the Joker
yeah listen who had the question here
what a strategy of guarding guarding
jokers in that category ain't nothing
you can do right now Joker's gonna get
his Keem gonna get his barking Shaq
gonna get his can't let D fish hit seven
threes can't let nine you know what I'm
saying you can't let Kenny Smith hit
nine three so they're gonna have to mix
it up like and and the Joker is a great
player smart enough to know when to take
over or no one debates you like a lot of
times he's coming Lakers double or just
you know turn their head and he's
kicking it and the others are making
shots so if I was the Lakers I'd say you
know what Joker go for 60 go for 50. I'm
because again Jokers MVP candy he gonna
get his but you can't let him get 34-15
and and 12 assists and let Bruce Brown
hit six threes and Aaron going here two
three well actually it was 22.
he's in that category with it ain't
nothing you can do double triple it
don't matter I agree with Shaq because
my thing with Joker is he's content to
get 20 points and 17 assists he not a
guy like I got to get my offensive
numbers like he's content to get a
triple double a lot of stars don't want
want to get they'd rather they want to
score 35 40 points instead of how 15-17
assists Joker's not in that category
um I I do agree because if they start
doubling him that lights up kcp brown
Aaron Gordon murderer yeah Porter oh
Porter that dude he reminds I tell you
what him and struce
uh him and struce when they miss I'm
shocked yeah I put Michael Porter Jr in
that category like I think it's true
since the same way I think every time
they missed a shot I'm like that's a
surprise but that's the Dilemma that
Shaq has point out the Jokers he content
in passing the ball yeah it's it's a
tall task
um but you say where's this I'm not
going to script tonight can I say it
because he's almost Superman he's
Superman who actually go on give it to
him
no no say it right Superman is in no
building yeah so you have to figure out
what's a Kryptonite is Ernie and the
only thing that's a visible Kryptonite
for him is he's not physically in shape
like Anthony Davis and and athletically
so okay how do we utilize that the one
thing that rui did would not work in the
second Joker figured that out but when
he's bringing the ball up as like that
point Center oh no we got a pressure
that's when you run to him you make him
work you got to bring it up make him
turn get him a little more fatigued so
he doesn't want to be an offensive
threat then the second part was we're
picking rolling him we got to get him in
the picking all day